hallo herzlich willkommen meine 1000
welt weiter zeige ich euch endlich wie
man von und herstellern unter euch die
wichtigsten passes ist von dann ist ein
supertag den benutzt man zu übersehen
von torten oder zu modellieren von
figuren und was ihr da an zutaten
benötigt zeigen sich jetzt ihr benötigt
900 bis 1000 gramm g siebte puderzucker
dann 120 milliliter bloße sirup das sind
etwa 170 gramm
ich habe jetzt hier den von party
versand glukosesirup ihr könnt aber auch
wenn ihr den nicht habt den hellen sirup
von grafschafter nehmen oder den
karamell seehof auf jeden fall muss das
ihr optik flüssig sein
dann braucht ihr eine tüte mal gelatine
das sieht ausgepackt so aus da könnt ihr
ganz normal diese gelatine benutzen und
werk eine schweinische benutzt kann auch
diese herrliche latina benutzen die kann
man im internet bestellen
ihr braucht 60 milliliter wasser dann
fünf kam zitronen soll die gibt's in der
großen packung oder auch in kleinen
abgepackten packungen und einen halben
teelöffel salz das sind auch ungefähr
fünf krank und die benötigt etwa zehn
gramm glyzerin das sollte pflanzliches
glyzerin sein das kann man sich in
apotheke kaufen oder mieten statt
adressen für die shops in denen er die
zutaten kaufen könnt verlinkt ich euch
hier unten in der infobox zu erstehen
die euch ist die gelatine und gibt da
das wasser mit dazu
das verriet ihr dann kurz miteinander
und lasst es dann etwa zehn minuten zum
quellen stehen
in der zwischenzeit könnt ihr euch dann
den glukose sirup ihren ställen und da
kommt dann das salz mir dazu die
zitronensäure und da kommt dann noch das
mystery mit dazu das sind 10 gramm also
etwa guten teelöffel zehn minuten später
sieht die relative dann so aus und ist
ziemlich fest und dann lasst es sie im
warmen wasserbad schmelzen oder macht
das ganze bei geringer temperatur in der
mikrowelle
wenn die charlotte dann aufgelöst ist
nehmen diese aus dem wasser bald heraus
schaut man mal nach ob sich wirklich
alles gelöst hat und dann könnte sie mit
der glukose masse verrühren
wenn ihr das dann habt dann gibt etwa
die hälfte des puderzucker in eine
schüssel der küchenmaschine
da kommt dann eine muntere und in die
fühlt ihr dann die gelatine glukose
masse ein
ich habe es gesehen dass wir die ganze
der falsche aufsatz drin war zum
vermischung braucht ihr nämlich den knet
aufsatz mit dem ruhr aufsatz klappt das
nämlich dass die küchenmaschine dann auf
etwas stufe 2 laufen und nach und nach
gibt es so viel puderzucker mit dazu
dass ihr ungefähr noch ein viertel als
250 gramm übrig habt
wenn dieser ungefähr noch ein viertel
vom puderzucker übrig hat macht die
maschine aus und den rest kneten wir
dann per hand ein dem restliche butter
sogar gebt ihr dann auf der
arbeitsfläche und stadien internet die
von damp master drauf und damit es nicht
euren händen klebt nehmt ihr euch am
besten dieses pamphlet panin das gibt's
einmal in fester form und einmal ein
paar - oft das ist eigentlich egal was
ihr nehmt und damit bleibt ihr euch
schön die hände ein denn ansonsten
bleibt später alles an den händen kleben
dann könnt ihr auch wunderbar dieses
ding hier abziehen und von den teig
resten befreien
und ich schreibe dann auch immer noch
intakt aber damit aus und kratz jetzt
die ganze masse aus der farbe
und jetzt wird es einfach alles noch ein
geknetet
wenn jedes tier den luftig den eine tüte
ein
am besten noch mal von außen komplett
einstreichen
und dann schön luftig vertreten
wenn ihr denn von den firmen wollten uns
die am besten lebensmittelfarben und
dazu eignet sich ganz gut verpassten die
kann man sich auch online bestellen die
nur für da zum beispiel diese von wilden
wilden einzigen carlos heißen die und
die gibt es auch in verschiedenen packs
zu kaufen und in verschiedenen farben
und ihr papa eine ganz geringe menge von
dem diesen ziemlich ergebnis und am
besten benutzt ihr dazu einen
zahnstocher um sie aus der packung zu
nehmen
so sehen die übrigens von innen euro
werden vom land stark einfärbung gold
gibt ihr die farbe am besten schon zur
stelle und blue große masse damit sich
die konsistenz nicht so verändert dann
könnt ihr ihn noch gut an zucker ein
bild wenn es nötig ist und ansonsten
könnt ihr die farbe einfach danach auch
ein kneten und könnte somit auch
verschiedene farben anwenden der von
kairo sind eingepackt einen tag im
kühlschrank ruhen
am nächsten tag solle die ihm zuerst auf
zimmertemperatur kommen lassen und dann
sorgfältig durchkneten und danach könnt
ihr in aus rohren um eure trocken damit
wir decken
ein beispiel wie ihr die toten
überziehen könnt habe ich bereits in
einem anderen video gezeigt und mit der
zeit werde ich auch immer mal wieder
dabei filmen nicht orten ein decke dass
er so ein bisschen ein einblick bekommt
wie das geht und dann bedanke ich mich
bei euch fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten mal